[Music]
all right uh hello i'm
sebastian idle from uh from play magnus
and i'm here with
uh the legend himself and the one and
only henry carson who
is uh whose genes is responsible for uh
a chess miracle well you could say half
the genes
half the genes fair enough fair enough
thanks for the uh
for the correction well do you want to
introduce him introduce yourself first
before we take
the questions because you guys have been
asking a lot of different questions
and we'll try to answer as many as
possible in this
interview well i'm a 58 year old
engineer soon 59. but i don't think i'll
spend too much time on
me as a private person because i'm here
because i'm
magnus is done basically so we should
focus on on chess
and a question related to my hangers
so yourself is not a topic you want
us to investigate further because you
are one hell of a guy i have to say
okay let's leave it at that that sounds
good
keep the curiosity i think yeah that's
probably the best way to go
well you guys have been asking a lot of
great questions i
i've been looking at all of them well
let's go
so the first question is from this is
quite funny because it's from a
a toy company who has like a huge
channel on youtube and they make really
great videos
and they're asking you what were magnus
favorite toys as a kid yeah that's an
interesting question because you know
magnus nice turned uh he turned 30
just before christmas but he still
hasn't got the driving license
although he was really into cars when he
was one and two
and three years old and when he was two
and a half he knew all the car brands
and so we if we were driving he would
point to the different cars the long
distance because he even knew the brand
and the model and so
cars and his tractor you know
caterpillar or john smith
maybe or john
yeah it's a famous tractor anyway he had
this model at home and he liked it a lot
he was also into
what we in norwegian called the captain
sableton he was a famous pirate
so he had the equipment piracy
equipment also and his sisters didn't
like that very much
he was one heck of a pirate at five
so he uh he knew all the car brands the
two and a half
yeah that is really impressive and
didn't he know all the municipalities in
norway at five
yeah four and five he was very much into
countries a number of populations
all the municipalities in norway looking
at the relationship
between size and population and
geography etc and
also especially the
municipality weapons or
brands in a way that you see along the
road that was very much something he
he liked it's open right yeah all right
so i think i mentioned
his main toys really as a child but he
was
quite a normal child and
he you okay also at four
he was very much into legos he was
building starting with small legos and
then building bigger and bigger ones
with up to 40 50 page instructions
for hours and hours really i was
building these huge legos and then
he was starting to get interested in
sports and reading about
sports and sports results at the age of
five
from then on it was mainly sports
and later chess
very impressive that's a great answer
i think you elaborated well on that
obviously considering that he
seemed very clever considering that he
could build legos
for hours and new all the municipalities
all the car brands etc
this just means that he has a tremendous
memory
when did you start believing that magnus
could pursue a career in
chess because obviously if you have a
great memory you're
you're well set for a chess career well
that's an important topic because at
first
i was right and then i was terribly
wrong for some time
and that's an experience i'd like to
share with parents
really because magnus had shown
interests and traits
that i thought would be well suited for
chess
like when he was two three four years
old so i tried to teach him
and his elder sister chess just before
he turned five
and they're like chess and we played
some typically in the autumn
like any hobby or activity that you do
with your children occasionally
but just seemed very difficult for them
so
fortunately i would say i was mistaken
and i didn't
have much ambition on their behalf
because i really underestimated how
difficult it is
to learn chess for a child and
especially
you can learn how the pieces move but to
get
two or more pieces to work together that
is very very hard
so frankly we played some chess magnus
was
reasonably interested but i didn't have
any ambitions on his behalf
until he started to get really
interested
on his own at seven and a half so yeah
when he was four i thought just might be
something for him
and then i mean i considered that a
non-topic for
several years afterwards really which
was
probably fortunate although it was
unbelievably stupid because it clearly
has a ton of features
right
right and at what point did his skills
surprise your own like when did he
become stronger
than you because you are a very strong
chess player yourself well i'm a
coffee house player but i i've been a
happy amateur
since i joined the club at 15 and then i
played for some years until
family and job took over and
when i started playing with magnus
when he really took up chess at seven
and a half eight years old
it just took about one year before he or
one and a half years maybe
before he surpassed me and i remember
the first time he beat me in blitz chess
at nine or eight and a half maybe even
i was quite proud because that hadn't
gone very fast
and i think although i i ended
uh higher on the results
resulting
list in one tournament when he was 11. i
think in general he surpassed me
at nine and that was
of course very promising because uh
it indicated that he might have
some real potential inches and we also
heard from other people like
seem like the same when names was nine
he saw one of his games
nine and two months ago and he said that
oh he can be a
grandmaster in five years so
he clearly showed some potential and it
was modern enough to beat me already
back there
and what is the last time when you did
b10 because a lot of people have been
wondering that
well in five against five it was
probably at nine
but we played quite a lot when we were
traveling
in the autumn of 2003 so
when i had one or one and a half minutes
or he had one or one and a half minutes
against mine
eight and a half or nine then i could
occasionally beat him
with this time handicap so
yeah you could say i haven't beaten him
for nearly 20 years and that's not an
issue really i mean
now i could spend the whole day
on the game and he could spend one
second for every move and he would still
be
and i think that's fantastic you don't
feel any frustration
or it wasn't uh well as a chess player
hobby player i can feel frustration on
my own part but not because my son is
beating me
that's good news right yeah toward
the creator of stock stockfish once said
that it was
just an amazing feeling what the engine
did beat him the first time i guess it's
a
it's a similar feeling yeah you could
say yeah
so if you want to go you can try play
henrik just released now in the
play magnus app so feel free to
challenge henrik yourself
i've tried the i've tried but it's
pretty hard
yeah you were really crushing myself
even trickier i can say
and as obviously as he is a
an incredible chess player he has a
like a huge competition instinct as we
say in the
region and that means that obviously
dislikes losing which is he has said
he has said that he is a sore loser he
really hates it
is there something that he hates more
than losing in just
isn't that enough well
he hates losing also in
soccer football and
[Music]
others other sports in general
any any games he hates losing really and
i thought it would be my task to teach
him to
lose with grace in chess and i tried a
bit but
on the other hand if you want to be a
really top player you have to hate
losing it has to really suck otherwise
you don't have the right mentality i
think to
continue to prove and improve and push
yourself
and reach your highest potential
i absolutely agree and as a chess player
and myself i can certainly relate to the
pain of
losing and it's like it's a common thing
that
that like why why does he get so angry
why is he such a bad loser like the tv
kind of pictures like that
and people who do not really have a clue
they also
they also think that's very strange and
he's such a bad loser i remember it was
quite a big deal in the norwegian media
at some point and magnus made a joke
if i don't uh what did he say like if i
don't get better
like happier when losing i will get
really angry if i don't manage to do it
but i think this is the mentality you
need to have like just as you said
because if you do not have this
mentality it will not improve
and also i think media they focus on
a few situations where he'd been
especially outspoken about his feelings
or shown his feelings
well normally you can tackle it
reasonably well like
like other top players basically
they're all human beings right
but i think that's uh that's the
mentality to have
but i'm obviously biased because i'm a
very sore loser myself
good for you but um
now that we um we have talked a little
bit about that uh
when did you realize that you could um
become like the best player
in the world potentially or that he had
or did he ever
could he ever imagine that he would
climb that high
i actually become the best player that
has ever lived according to a lot of
people
myself inclusive i don't know if my
memory serves me 100
correct but
i had a terminity or what it's called
at one point at least mentally to
compare
his development with kasparos
already when he was nine and a half i
think and
at that point he had started later he
was still maybe lagging somewhat but
at night and a half i thought the sky is
telemetry
this could go anywhere
yeah it really is uh mind-blowing to
think
just how can someone beat that girl and
just well i mean
you don't have to be that good just a
little bit better than the others
i'm partly joking because it's uh of
course
the thought process is going into into
high level chests they're very complex
you need a lot of knowledge
good intuition quick mind and all these
things
good memory but somehow
if your conceptual understanding is just
slightly better
than the others it might look it might
look very impressive
but the difference can be quite
small really and
magnus has spent a lot of time on chess
i mean when he was eight nine ten years
older trade talked about
chess all the time still i think chess
is always at the back of his mind
and of course when you spend a lot of
time on the topic
you you improve and you mature and
develop and what seems
difficult for others can be relatively
easy for you
but it still seems like a mystery how
could you become better from
2750 to 28.50 let's say
because that's uh well you know minus
he looked back three or four years ago
at his
level as a 20 year old and after all
he was the top-ranked player at 20
and he was just astounded by
his lack of understanding of a lot of
position
at 20 when he was 25 26 years old
he couldn't necessarily play any better
over the board but his
understanding had dramatically improved
also
from a very high level so
i think also it's worth mentioning that
the computers that have really shown us
that this
sky is the limit in chess really that
there's a lot of
room for improvement and even at 2800
you make a lot of
mistakes that a computer would consider
basic
right yeah and even they make mistakes
yeah even now they tend to beat each
other yeah which is
uh just uh truly incredible yeah really
so a few people have asked how magnus
was as a as a kid did he have the same
sense of humor
as yeah was he as funny as now
well people change but
we had a lot of fun with the kids when
they were young magnus
has always had a lot of humor he's maybe
more serious
[Music]
as an adult simply because there's a lot
of focus on him
and people expect a lot from him
and he's of course aware of his position
and he's interviewed or talking to fans
or playing chess at high level
in tournaments so that he he's probably
uh more fun in private than
in public i can imagine that
that's usually the case too because of
course public you need to have a certain
figure but
we've seen him joke around a lot in his
banters and stuff so maybe we've seen
this private side there that's part of
it
yeah because he has a great sense of
humor at least
typical dad jokes
has he learned them from you or well you
know
there was an old saying
was it mark twain i think who said that
amazingly when he was 15 his father was
a complete [ __ ] than they did but when
mark was 20 his father had became
had become quite normal and
i think that's showing you that
although children don't necessarily
want to be like their parents they
develop some of the same traits
and humor and
characteristics so i'm afraid that
some of the bad jokes magnus are making
he might
have been inspired by me
right and some people have asked also if
magnus had um
an immediate talent or did his
brilliancy
just come over time immediately yeah
like immediate talent like
you learn the game and then yeah is that
incredible as i mentioned
chest was very hard for these kids when
he was four and a half five years old
his sister was six
so kind of i
i think if anything compared to other
so-called geniuses magnus
considers himself to be a slow learner
but in a way he doesn't stop learning he
keeps
keeps going and then if you keep going
you get better
you just spend enough time there you'll
get quite good in there
so my impression was not that he was
kicking up chess that early quickly
early on
and in fact one of his not trainers but
one of the people we talked to early on
when magus was nine
he knew about magnus's
overall level of knowledge within chess
like
opening knowledge and all the books he
had read
and he told me in private that he was a
bit surprised that magnus
didn't show even more promise or better
results because he knew so much
but i think that that didn't work me at
all because i
understood i think that
even if you know a lot of stuff to to to
bring that into motion kind of and
to use it actively during a chess game
that's a
process that requires time and
maturing et cetera so that now magnus
was not
particularly quick learner earlier
but he was i think his main
ability was this ability
to focus and be interested and curious
and continue to pursue
knowledge and understanding that's the
key basically
right right and did you have any other
interests when he was
a kid because i know he's always been
fond of sports and i believe
he probably was that from the very
beginning wasn't he yeah he was
interested in
in sport definitely he was he was quite
doing well at school early on
before he lost interest a bit after
after some time but so he was good with
numbers
geography history he knew a lot about
politics early on
etc but more and more really sports
been his main interest i think because
it's
an obvious and
exciting way to occasionally focus on
something else than chess to get his
mind away from chess he can
look at other sports and he's quite into
fantasy football as you may
know spending a lot of time on that and
that's a great
stress reliever i think also during
tournaments for instance right
yeah he did have the number one spot at
some point in the world
yeah a couple of times or once maybe
[Music]
last year yeah yeah that's of course
an incredible achievement
and uh well magnus is like quite a funny
guy is known for his
banter and he does have this banter with
some other
world-class players like anishigiri what
uh what do you think about
that well
anish he's been historically commenting
a lot on things magnus has said and done
and they've had lots of fun i think
at some point uh it seemed to get more
serious
uh but i i don't know i
i don't understand really what's going
on to me
social media and banter is it's all
about fun and i hope that's
the same for everyone involved
i'm sure these two guys aren't known as
being the most
serious guys in the world well
i don't know i don't know
and do you have any
funny stories about magnus as a kid any
fun stories you want to
you want to share because even i am
curious about that
i must admit well fun stories i don't
know
i of course have but frankly there's a
one story that is not particularly fun
although it
ended well we went
my parents had a hot tub in the
mountains and we went
to a local mountain top
and on one side of the mountain this was
very steep
and magnus was sometimes he was going to
chip so he was sometimes a bit ahead of
the family
and on one of these trips
he got lost basically we couldn't find
him and it turned out he had taken a
different
route going back from the top and we had
so when we were looking for him he was
going past us so i spent some time going
up and down and down the
steep hill
which was quite scary basically on the
other side
looking for him as a fearing
worst case scenario and but then in an
hour or so when the others had to return
to the hut
i i could go out on the brink and i
could see they were waving
on the on the roof of the
hut and then i understood and i could
also see
or suspect that he was back at that
that was a bit scary really
and fortunately we've not had
any serious
[Music]
episodes or things happening to the
children any other children
so that's why this relatively
trivial episode of him getting lost in
the mountain for
an hour or two was something that really
sticks
in my mind yeah i can imagine
great story happy that it got
got a great ending otherwise the chess
world would have been slightly different
yeah let's stay today
and well you kind of talked about this
too that
did you kind of make him study chess or
is this just something he did because he
wanted to because we have this russian
dad at least
since my dad is also eastern european
kind of forces the chest on you like you
got to study that you got to study this
etc my dad was kind of like that
yeah and how were you no well i mean
okay there's a couple of answers i could
give to that
on the one hand the obvious answer is
that uh no of course not
now it would never work with magnus
because he
he's always been very independent
pursuing his own interests
and if i have tried to push him it would
never worked
and maybe the success is partly or
at least yeah partly partly because
we didn't kind of dampen or destroy his
interest for chess in any way
by pushing him in any specific direction
and i also learned when he was
nine we were looking through one of his
games
and i was trying to tell him about
the pawn patterns and opposite color
bishops
and then the master played came over and
he said no that's wrong he said it's not
like that
and then i thought well that's not
the first time
that i've said something
wrong about chess designers but it will
be the last time
so at that point when he was nine i i
really completely stopped trying to
teach him anything
that had to do with chess and he was
also
quite close to my level already at nine
and a month
so it made sense anyhow but the other
way of interpreting
things that is that
well parents they have a lot of
influence on children
so if you are subtle about it maybe you
can
influence your children without
them even knowing too much about it
seems like it did work out though great
strategy
well i'll leave that to the others too
to guess some philosophers
yeah because there have been several
approaches uh you did polygor strategy
in particular is
quite different yeah but it did work out
as well yeah
and well how much did he study did he
did he spend time with his family or
maybe it compromised his time with his
family that he just studied
all day well he tried to combine it so
typically after school
he did some chess or some some outdoor
sports and
during dinner he would very soon start
to
eat at his own table so that he could
have the chess board and or and possibly
a book by
his side so we would eat dinner at the
same time
but that two different tables and he
would he would
be doing chess while eating basically
and my wife and i we were being slightly
worried about this development but on
the other hand
you could ask him things he was cup and
the tables were close by and it was just
a convenient way of allowing him to
pursue one of his at that time several
interests
because he was really dwelling into
things at an early age
and then we didn't think we should stop
him basically
so you decided to just be his backbone
his entire time
yeah i mean of course it's a dream come
true
if you can pursue your interests and
hobbies and make a living from it
and never have to kind of
[Music]
suffer at work or or
do a lot of things that you don't really
don't appreciate
doing really so he's been fortunate in
that sense
right and well the natural question is
then
what would he do what would he do if it
wasn't for chess would he pursue a
normal career perhaps or
maybe he would pursue a different sport
early on he said that well he would
really have liked to be a top
footballer and later on he said that
well no i'm happy being a top chess
player that's
it's fine he was very much into numbers
and as i said i think on
another occasion that i think he could
have been a decent
stock trader if he had been interested
really interested in that but
being a top chess player i mean why why
should we worry about what the
alternative he could have done here
although chess is a
game and a hobby it's also something
that brings
enormous amount of enjoyment to
audiences and people following the games
so
i think he's doing something very
worthwhile uh with his life
yeah obviously well with that memory the
sky's the limit so
no matter if it wasn't chess it probably
would have been something where he
could have used those abilities i don't
know it's fine
there's numerous possibilities
very difficult to know but that's a
common question
so but all right a uh pretty
fun question again that made me laugh a
bit
and that is are you more proud
of magnus than your other kids because
this is kind of
a i don't know it's it's a
tough situation i i i guess but i
at least find myself some at least
sometimes liking some of my siblings
more than
the other and some of my family members
in general of course it's an
interesting question and it's a relevant
topic now because i like
i know in the next trick series the
crown
this has been a recurring topic
in the last last season
and well frankly for me and my wife
we've really loved our children all our
children
so much that
you could say that when you
really love all your children
the feelings you have for them are at
such a level
that being occasionally extremely proud
of one of them
in particular doesn't diminish your
relationship to the others it just
enhances this feeling of
[Music]
things are good life is good and uh
you're
happy with with kind of
the sum of uh
what's happening to you and your family
and your children and etc
so fortunately for me that's not
much of a relevant topic and
anyhow you would have to ask my
daughters i think if they
experienced something different in this
area than
what i'm expressing but
of course when there's a lot of focus on
manga specifically
uh you you might have more feelings
about him
for a brief period of time occasionally
while again i'm not sure that's relevant
really and
i know also his sisters who do
very well on their own and great human
beings
they're also proud of their brothers so
i don't i i try not to think of this
as a problematic topic at all basically
we're just
in a fortunate situation as a family
so it doesn't make different that is
like the world champion
just well my wife is very down to earth
so like to to her he's just magnus i
mean
with his traits which is he has had from
a young age and whether his world
champion or not i mean
eat your supper anyway whatever so
it's uh i think you shouldn't
feel surprised too much about
uh the concept of what implies to be a
world champion
he's a human being he enjoys enjoying
what he's doing and he's very successful
what is doing but it's
it's all supposed to be fun and
meaningful
but it must be quite a feeling to be the
father of a world champion
yeah of course fantastic and but it's
become it's
become that way quite gradually although
for magnus it's
it's the only thing he knows basically
he's the world champion what are you i
mean
that's his life yeah well for me as a
hobby player i have
quite a different perspective of
world champions than i have now that my
son has become one
but that has also happened relatively
gradually although
of course i've had to pinch my arm
occasionally
and maybe even now i say i pinch my
arms arm occasionally but no
i'm quite used to it i know that he's
very good at chess
just tremendous success it's been
a fantastic journey and
we are very fortunate my wife i
the family norwegians yeah yeah for sure
but it's it's really just well
that's that's my life now of course i'm
happy about it
yeah i can't imagine how how it
would how it would be but because
but yeah we certainly earned him a lot
of gratitude
in norway and how he has brought
norwegian chess
forward uh the reaching chess is now
shown
on tv every time he plays the tournament
basically and it's all thanks to him
we didn't see that coming yeah it's
really it is and it is incredible so
uh thanks to you
i i can say and uh
how's your style of chess compared to
him like did your sound
playing chess did it influence him you
think fortunately not much
i'm really a coffee house player playing
for tricks
swindles if i if i can win on time in
bits that's fine
i mean while magnus is more a classical
positional player at heart
so unfortunately we're quite different
and what about um and this is of course
at a completely different level
that should be added and what about
physically like
let's say you 30 years ago would you
beat him in a fight now
well that's a good question no not 30
years ago
maybe now
no no i will fight now he's
he's quite strong
he i'm tall and thin and
maybe he has some of his build from his
grandfather fathers who were more
physical so
all right but are you would you say that
you're better than any sports
well norwegian television 2 they asked
me about this and
maybe if we go many many hours of
cross-country skiing he will finally
be at the back at some point but
generally of course he's better
than his old father
and that's fine
right magnus once said that you made him
believe that chess is more fun than
video games how did he achieve that
that was a good one well we were a bit
restrictive on
video games with the kids because
we thought we should limit the number of
hours per day et cetera
spent on the computer early on and
somehow magnus got the impression that
while playing chess
was okay ordinary
video games was not considered as
useful or as a
helpful training or things
to spend your time and somehow that that
worked out well
well there you go
uh if magnus was candy what flavor would
he be
well if he he was an animal he's
he wanted to be a crocodile so maybe it
would be
peppers maybe chili peppers
and is that candy yeah you can get candy
with chili peppers
yeah you have the red hot chili peppers
[Music]
and how's his music taste
in comparison to yours no i'm just
joking
he's really into music although maybe a
bit old-fashioned i think he liked
music from the 80s 90s etc also modern
music
and he's not that much into classicals
probably so that's a topic we still have
to cover
and with movies i guess uh he knows a
lot of
[Music]
movies
so he's you have to ask him basically
i think he can do a lot of stuff when it
comes to movies
well it's been a lot of fun i
certainly have been filled in with a lot
of
info a lot of interesting information
you won't tell anyone right
it's just oh don't worry this is uh just
between us
don't have to worry it will not be shown
anywhere okay
[Music]
do you have anything to add do you want
to tell us a fun fact about yourself
perhaps
because there's no fun about me i'm a
very serious guy so
but uh sebastian you you've done a great
job it's been
oh thank you i'm thrilled being here
with you and i look forward to see your
next
interview yeah might be one of your
daughters
maybe but i gotta interview the whole
family at some point
good luck with that yeah i imagine that
your wife will be the toughest one
yeah she's that'll be difficult
but uh it is what it is
well thank you so much henry carson and
um
i'm sure we'll see you around soon
remember that you can play henrik and
play magnus hack right now that is one
hell of a ride
he is a tactical opponent quite quite
strong
and he certainly was a great player in
his prime
so keep going
so that's a great challenge remember
that and as always we'll see you soon
[Music]
here
you